à tous voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce vendredi
nous reviendrons bien sûr ce soir sur la
mort de pascal sevran homme de télé
parolier passionnés et défenseurs de la
chanson française
auteur de romans il décédé aujourd'hui
d'un cancer à l'âge de 62 ans
dans un instant de nombreuses réactions
michel drucker est également avec nous
comment éviter l' escalade au liban on
ne parle plus désormais de crise
politique mais de menace de guerre
civile des affrontements ont à nouveau
eu lieu aujourd'hui à beyrouth entre
milice du hezbollah et partisans
sunnites du gouvernement un nouveau
dispositif sur les routes après la
police voici les gendarmes en civil dans
des voitures banalisées
ils ont fait leur apparition et le
résultat est probant les pv tombe une
expérience dans sept départements qui
sera bientôt généralisée le joli mois de
mai et ses ponts à répétition difficile
parfois de s'organiser pour les familles
travaillent ou rtt école ouverte ou
fermée à chacun ses solutions
illustration à dans un instant enfin le
football et le suspense jusqu'au bout en
haut du classement lyon et bordeaux lens
farhi et toulouse tout en bas demain
soir vers 22h30 on en saura un peu plus
en attendant vous le verrez les
supporters eux s'inquiètent ce soir de
très nombreux téléspectateurs sont
tristes ils ont perdu un ami pascal
sevran
les emmener dans sa passion durant des
années passion pour la chanson française
aujourd'hui l'animateur le parolier
l'homme aux célèbres coups de gueule
mais également le romancier s'est éteint
il avait 62 ans
et il souffrait depuis quelques temps
d'un cancer dans un instant nous
retrouvons michel drucker mais tout
d'abord les premières réactions avec
christophe ayrault et jean marie le
quartier pascal sevran ne se rendra plus
à morterolles son refuge du limousin
sa famille a annoncé officiellement son
décès en début d'après midi
victime d'un cancer à 62 ans depuis 25
ans il était ami bernard brouille se
souvient des passages de pascal sevran
dans la région et venaient chars sur
cher les ninjas
sa belle maison et il avait de qualité
c'était un travailleur est un
perfectionniste
pour l'homme de télévision ses démons de
la chanson et de la politique qui
arrivent les zonages pascal a tout
réussi en définitive il voulait être
chanteur n'a pas été peut-être chanteuse
à ses deux jumelles high tech sentir
beaucoup plus tard mais c'est un énorme
il est clé des chansons on a travaillé
pour les dans les années 70 cela crée
beaucoup de titres dalit à onesse et
nuit bon on avait droit - chevalier à ta
traîner à brel à ce genre de houssen des
artistes un peu plus comme il tangue et
& company est donc là aussi les
imitaient à chaque fois non les 8 heures
il y eut mais ils peuvent penser disait
que ses chansons donc pas mourir
quoiqu'en au micron a traversé des
tempêtes ou des moments durs parce
qu'avec est là pour dire sur l'affection
son amitié et son soutien avec ficr avec
quoi
du côté nos gentils matin à paris en
l'église saint-louis-en-l'ile anouma
genou sera rendue avant les obsèques
dans l'intimité familiale
à quelques kilomètres de morterolles on
avait l'habitude de résumer la vie de
pascal sevran à sa partie la plus
visible celle d'un animateur de
télévision populaire celui qui aimait la
chanson à l'ancienne comme on dit mais
sa vie fut beaucoup plus riches
pascal sevran s'appelait en fait jean
claude jouault une vie un destin que
nous raconte olivier l'ena il lui avait
donné le premier sa chance à la télé
patrick bruel ne l'a jamais oublié
c'était exactement le 16 janvier 84 ou
tu m'avais très gentiment offert ton
plateau pour que c'est vrai que quand
j'ai entendu que tu faisais une dernière
émission par mon grand regret en tout
cas j'ai bah oui je me dis qu est l
envie de venir tôt salué pendant plus de
vingt ans le même décor les mêmes
mouffe le monde plaisir faire découvrir
très belle voix des nouvelles voies dans
la chanson française elle se porte bien
j'essaie de le démontrer jeune garçon
coiffeur il avait un rêve devenir
chanteurs célèbres
le je t'aime
bondues m
grâce à la télévision une conquête un
public beaucoup se déplacer en bus pour
voir en vrai celui qui les accompagnait
celui qu'il regardait sur le petit écran
et qu'il venait applaudir lors de galas
aux quatre coins de france
oui
est-ce que dalle dans toute sa vie il la
passa en musique
logique car en france tout commence et
tout finit par des chansons
tout commence donc par une chanson 1964
un inconnu est filmé dans le public du
petit conservatoire de mireille
il venait d'avoir 18 ans il venait
d'avoir 18 ans il était mon corps
non sens
volcom et non
la plus célèbre des 500 chansons que
pascal sevran a écrite j'ai quand même
le doyen
et dans le temps
elle ne pouvait fournir des chansons à
succès dans le monde 3 millions de
disques vendus
dalida apporter sa formidablement et
jolie il ya sept ou huit réduction
lobbies
je ne pouvais m
dalida par son intermédiaire parce
qu'elles se rencontrent françois
mitterrand il devient l'un des intimes
du président qu'il accompagne chaque
année lors de la traditionnelle
ascension de la roche de solutré proche
de jacques lange amis de bertrand
delanoë il affiche sa sympathie pour
nicolas sarkozy lors de la dernière
campagne présidentielle
suis-je toujours de gauche cette
question ne se pose plus françois
mitterrand est mort tu viens bien le
résumé pascal sevran dans sa campagne du
limousin
c'est ici qu'ils se retirent fin 2006
pour fuir la polémique après des mots
jugés racistes au sujet de la natalité
en afrique
c'est ici qu'il aime écrire quelques
romans le premier le passé
supplémentaires reçoit le prix roger
nimier
en 2000 il publie la vie sans lui
premier tome de son journal intime suis
souvent content réjouit émus bouleversés
voilà heureux faut se garder des grands
mots décoré de la légion d'honneur en
2004 par jean pierre raffarin salué dans
la cravate par gilbert bécaud pascal
sevran remercier surtout par son public
rémy qui tout ça lui donne à la chance à
la chanson voilà un personnage de télé
une personnalité engagée cultivé et
parfois excessive et qu'il n'essaie pas
indifférent avec nous maintenant michel
drucker en direct du journal la provence
avignon bon sens michel
alors pascal sevran c'était un bon soir
l'euro personnage est une vraie
personnalité
ah oui c'était un caractère bien trempé
c'était une vraie personnalité
parisienne conscience littéraire du
terme mais vous l'avez bien résumé dans
ces images c'était quelqu'un de
contradictoire
c'était un autodidacte il faut se
souvenir qu'il avait un cap2 coiffure il
était garçon coiffeur charge de 18 ans
avant d'entrer au petit conservatoire de
mireille mireille évidemment il a l'a
retrouvé là-bas beaucoup de chanteurs
comme françoise hardy et surtout il a
rencontré emmanuel berl qui était
l'époux le philosophe l'intellectuel le
mari de mireille qui l'a fait rencontrer
le tout paris littéraire car résumer la
carrière de pascal sevran a la chance
aux chansons c'est un peu réducteur
bien sûr il adorait la chanson bien sûr
il a fait chanter et danser la france au
quotidien pendant 20 ans et pas
seulement que les maisons de retraite
car il faut rappeler que patrick fiori
que patricia kaas que laurent gerra
patrick bruel nous avons entendu et bien
d'autres dany brillant ont débuté leur
carrière pour la première alors jean les
caméras c'est parce qu'elle se vend
justement stanhome de télé mais il faut
retenir également qu'il était un homme
d'écriture de culture est un vrai vrai
passionné de politique absolument alors
c'est emmanuel berl qui lui fait
rencontrer chez mireille le tout paris
qui pétillent les intellectuels il va
rencontrer jean d'ormesson qui présidera
le jury du prix roger nimier
il aura vous l'avez dit le prix roger
nimier premier roman il a écrit beaucoup
d'autres romans il a écrit évidemment
beaucoup de journaux ou de journaux
intimes qu est un succès considérable
il en a consacré à son ami stéphane ne
s'est jamais remis vraiment d'ailleurs
de la disparition de son ami stéphane
mais c'était un passionné de politique
il était souvent avec françois
mitterrand je me souviens qu'un jour
françois mitterrand recevait à la che le
couple gorbatchev il avait demandé à
pascal de venir avec son accordéoniste
pour chanter les grandes chansons du
patrimoine culturel pour gorbatchev
alors c'était quelqu'un vous l'avez dit
qui montait la marge de celui très
pendant dix ans avec mitterrand ça l'a
pas empêché d'être séduits par nicolas
sarkozy il n'est pas le seul dans la
liste des socialistes qui auraient été
séduits par sarkozy elle est longue mais
c'était quelqu'un qui aimait le le débat
politique et mais la discussion il avait
d indignation il avait des emportements
il avait une plume brillante acérées et
spirituelle caustique
c'était assez d'être un vrai personnage
michel deux choses importantes vrai
qu'on en reparle vous venez de citer la
disparition de son ami stéphane et puis
la polémique autour de son livre et ses
propos sur la natalité en afrique
bah oui alors ça c'était c'était un
drame dans sa vie la polémique là
vraiment beaucoup matin il a été très
affecté tout ça par les proportions
compris ses écrits qu'on avait retrouvé
dans un de ses journaux intimes bien
deux ou trois ans ça l'avait un peu
dépassé il s'en est excusé expliqué mais
ça m'a beaucoup marqué d'ailleurs bon si
on en avait parlé port mais toujours été
toujours est-il oui bien sûr toujours
est il qu'il est tombé malade et
gravement malade
quelques semaines après ce drame après
cette polémique donc il avait été très
touché par tout ça il s'était beaucoup
retirer à morterolles on l'appeler de
temps en temps de laisser des messages y
les écouter on correspondait par écrit
mais je voudrais dire que pascal sevran
laissera dans les archives de la
télévision des images importante
1 c'est vrai qu'il a maintenue souvent à
bout de bras la vraie chanson française
il
des chanteurs souvent en perdition il a
beaucoup aidé et georgette lemaire il a
beaucoup écrit pour d'autres il a
apporté une télévision qui n'existait
pas mais il faut se souvenir aussi de sa
plume il aurait très bien pu réussir à
la tête d'un magazine littéraire c'est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement doux et ses
parents étaient des communistes
convaincu son père chauffeur de taxi qui
distribue l'humanité tous les dimanches
il a baigné dans le militantisme même si
lui n'a jamais appartenu à un parti
politique c'est quelqu'un qui aura
marqué la télévision et qui est mort
malheureux il était très malheureux déjà
depuis quelques années depuis la
disparition de stéphane c'était un très
grand anxieux il avait une espèce
inaptitude au bonheur c'était un très
très grand inquiet assez anxiogène qui
vous communiquer son anxiété ses
angoisses ses doutes ses stress
voilà mais vous relire ce qu'il a écrit
il a écrit dont il a écrit de très bons
livres
si vous voulez bien vers 22h35 on vous
montrera dans le premier vivement
dimanche combien consacrer tous ses
personnages et tous et pascal sevran
différents merci beaucoup michel drucker
pour ce témoignage rendez vous donc ce
soir à 22h35
et puis mercredi je crois pour un un
hommage à 14 heures il faut éviter à
tout prix le terrible engrenage de la
guerre civile au liban la phrase est de
bernard kouchner mais elle est reprise
en écho par de nombreuses personnalités
politiques
la france n'entend pas rester inactif
face à la crise que traverse une
nouvelle fois le pays et beyrouth en
particulier les affrontements se sont
poursuivis dans l'ouest de la ville
entre les forces chiite du hezbollah et
les partisans sunnites du gouvernement
ont fait le point ce soir avec gérard
griesbeck
le hezbollah a gagné après 48 heures de
combat ils contrôlent maintenant
beyrouth voix et c'est à dire tout le
quartier musulman de la capitale
libanaise
la victoire assurée les miliciens font
la loi dans des rues quasi désertes
mais le hezbollah ne cherche pas
occupait le terrain une fois l'ennemi
sunnite chassés ils demandent à l'armée
régulière de prendre la relève
les forces pro-gouvernementales ont été
balayés alors quelques manifestants
dénoncent le hezbollah la défaite 1
amer le genre du hezbollah on vous tue
rang anna devait faire la guerre à
israël mais c'est à nous qui fait la
guerre maintenant tous les médias que
possède la famille hariri ont été
obligés de fermer plus de télévision
plus de radio plus de journaux le
hezbollah veut conserver ses propres
réseaux de communication que le
gouvernement cherche à lui enlever pour
cela les miliciens chiites bloquent
toujours l'aéroport et le port de
beyrouth en fin d'après midi les
habitants ont profité de l'accalmie pour
s'approvisionner sur les marchés depuis
trois jours ils étaient 4 chez eux ce
lieu que nous sortir alors qu'elles ne
le monde devrait jamais tué un autre
marcheur les concessions rien n'indique
que les combats vont cesser ce soir pour
le moment beyrouth est à majorité
chrétienne n'a pas été touchée par les
affrontements
alors le pays semble donc une nouvelle
fois au bord du ko je vous rappelle que
le liban était confronté à une guerre
civile de 1975 à 1990 que les pays est
bloqué politiquement le poste de
président restent vacants et c'est dans
ce contexte que le hezbollah a lancé
cette offensive d'air tout cela paraît
comme souvent le spectre de l'iran et de
la syrie
renaud bernard c'était il ya deux ans
protégé par une vitre blindée
le leader du hezbollah hassan nasrallah
crie victoire
la foule de ses partisans est à ses
pieds
après 34 jours de guerre contre l'armée
israélienne le mouvement chiite a poussé
son ennemi au cessez-le-feu
le parti de dieu vient de démontrer au
monde entier qu au liban il est un état
à l'intérieur de l'état
il dispose de combattants le stock
d'armes
mais il a aussi à son service des
entreprises et des chaînes de télévision
qui diffuse sa propagande
jusqu'à présent le hesbollah contrôle et
déjà tout le sud liban ici en jaune armé
par la syrie qui considère le pays comme
une province est financé par l'iran avec
lequel le hezbollah partagent un même
objectif rayer israël de la carte
depuis l'automne les députés chiites
paralyse la désignation d'un nouveau
président de la république
cela fait cinq mois que le pays du cèdre
n'a plus de chef de l'état 18 réunion du
parlement libanais ont déjà été ajourné
désormais le hezbollah fait planer le
spectre d'un retour à la guerre civile
des combats de rue dans lesquels toutes
les communautés du pays se sont déchirés
il ya 30 ans voilà pour la crise
libanaise dans l'actualité de ce
vendredi en france il y aurait une
nouvelle fois beaucoup de monde sur les
routes ce week-end et en cas
d'infraction ne soyez pas surpris vous
allez peut-être découvrir un nouveau
dispositif de contrôle des gendarmes en
civil à bord de voitures ou sur des
motos banalisées
actuellement seuls sept départements
sont concernés mais tout cela sachez le
devrait être généralisé dans les
prochains mois fanny spengler et samuel
humez aise
sous vos yeux l' arme secrète de la
gendarmerie
vous ne remarquez rien et pourtant sous
ce blouson de motard se cache un
gendarme en civil et un 4 4 derrière moi
le conducteur n'a pas la ceinture reçu
les reçus concernant véhicule
quelques minutes plus tard le 4 4 est
interpellé puis verbalisé à l'intérieur
c'est la stupéfaction du étonné il ya un
vantard cuir la voiture hébert j'ai tout
simplement je meurs pourquoi autant le
cinéma
les patrouilles en moto mais aussi en
voiture banalisée et gendarmes en bus
qui interpellent deux à trois fois plus
qu'une patrouille classique
une tactique ultra efficace c'est la
discrétion la discrétion l'oeil du
gendarme
là il ya un téléphone voyez sur une
absence qui a break de couleur bleu nuit
c'est une femme au volant donc on va
procéder à son interpellation
c'est leur premier réflexe mettre en
avant leurs uniformes voit parfaitement
s'identifier auprès de la conductrice à
présent pour surtout ne pas faire peur
bonjour madame tout à fait gendarmerie
donc je conseille une amende de 22 euros
et la sensation que rien absolument rien
n'est pardonné aujourd'hui au volant
c'est bien et puis et mal maintenant ce
sera bien pour ceux qui le méritent
vraiment pas qu'ils feront des grosses
fautes en pour les gendarmes ce
dispositif testé depuis cinq mois et
très efficace au mois de juin il devrait
être étendu à 12 autres départements
xavier darcos a reçu aujourd'hui les
syndicats de lycéens qui protestent
toujours contre les suppressions de
postes prévues pour la rentrée prochaine
le ministre de l'éducation qui a annoncé
la mise en place en septembre d'un
dispositif de soutien au lycée justement
lors 200 les établissements en grande
difficulté une mesure qui a fait l'objet
d'un accord avec les syndicats un
soutien scolaire qui existe déjà dans
les collèges voyant à quoi tout cela se
ressemblent avec le reportage de mallory
ao nous et de marie cros parce que
plusieurs quêtes valent mieux qu'une ici
on fait ses devoirs ensemble deux heures
le soir quand les cours sont fils me
trouvais doctor et deux professeurs pour
une dizaine d'élèves
ça change tout hannezo j'arrive pas trop
parce qu'elles sont censées plein de
choses comme quoi c'était plus qu'ils
sont amis la télé ils ne savent pas à
prendre des leçons ils ont besoin qu'on
les aide qu'on leur dise comment faire
qu'on les fasse très vite et qu'on les
interroge beaucoup ils sont vraiment
demandeur par rapport à 108,74 non
maintenant on s'est vus 174 m et si le
desimlock je suis d'accord c'est juste
mais je réponds pas la question pour
force par m pap à 105e où je sais pour
sa vie ces études professeurs comme
élèves sont volontaires quatre
collégiens sur dix se sont inscrits on
craignait que les plus fragiles goût de
l'étude
ce n'est pas le cas
à la suite des conseils de classe du
premier trimestre des élèves de
troisième et de quatrième sont venus
volontairement nous demander de l'aide
et de l'accompagnement éducatif
s'ils sont séduits c'est que la compagne
mais ne signe pas haute voix théâtre
initiation aux premiers secours chorale
danse arabe
l'établissement propose 17 ateliers dont
le grappling un mélange de lutte judo et
ju-jitsu bien connu dans les quartiers
les jeunes ont sollicité l'activité soit
tombé quand on a besoin d'eux avait du
mal chez nous nous devons aider ces
élèves là qui sont pour la nage en
partie en difficulté apprennent à la
fois la patience le respect la tension y
arrive à trouver des qualités chez eux
ce ne retrouverons pas dans certaines
matières et donc au sein du collège au
quotidien ça se ressent ça apaise
meilleures notes meilleurs rapports avec
les profs entre élèves
l'accompagnement éducatif sera étendue à
tous les collèges et aux quelques 5000
300 écoles prioritaire dès la rentrée
prochaine l'école toujours qui comme les
entreprises se retrouvent à devoir gérer
les ponts ce mois de mai certains
établissements étaient ouverts
aujourd'hui d'autres fermés alors
comment les familles s'organisent face à
ces vacances ou rtt parfois forcés
reportage julien duperey et vincent
barras aux côtés de cette couturière du
nord de paris un apprenti un peu
particulier sofiane six ans comme pour
tous les petits parisiens
pas d'école aujourd'hui mais impossible
pour sa maman de lâcher son commerce
alors il a passé la journée entre vestes
et pantalons et la lorie ça coûte très
cher et puis on trouve pas comme ça
quelqu'un tout y était
ce n'est qu'ils soient à l'école avec
d'autres enfants ou dans un jardin
plutôt ici avec la maman ou papa altrad
travail et s'établit à eux ont pu
s'adapter pas d'école non plus mais un
pique nique ensoleillé
cette mère de famille elle a pris une
journée de rtt pour garder ses deux
enfants et les trois autres d'une amie
plutôt dur l'organisation du mois de mai
soc 15 jours de vacances enchaîné sur un
pont de cinq jours puis sur la grève de
jeudi puis sur la grève du 22 pour ceux
qui ont des enfants à la crèche
c'est clair que c'est compliqué c'est
assez pénible l'école ou pas écoles
ponts ou papon à chaque académie une
organisation particulière ici dans cette
crèche d'entreprise on s'attendait à
recevoir pas mal d'enfants privés
d'école mais finalement il n'y a pas eu
de demande s'il y en avait vu on n'y
aurait pas répondu mais ça pas été
nécessaire cette région ont fait le
point en fait je pense que la plupart
des gens
et puis il y a ceux qui avaient école
comme ici à saint-ouen en
seine-saint-denis
pas de pont pour les enfants ni pour les
parcs j'imagine à mon avis qu'il doit y
avoir pas mal d'absences aujourd'hui
savourer ça aurait pu avoir le chip en
dormois long week end le long week-end
pas pour tout de suite ici demain matin
il y à aussi écoles seuls lundi sera
férié
et là ce sera pour tous mais allez
l'économie maintenant avec un nouveau
record pour le baril de pétrole à new
york et il ne faut pas s'en réjouir il a
dépassé aujourd'hui le seuil des 126
dollars concrètement cette hausse est
ressenti entre autres sur le carburant
mais également sur le prix du gaz qui
est depuis des années un excès sur celui
du pétrole mais finalement pourquoi un
tel lien entre le pétrole et le gaz tout
cela mérite bien quelques explications
valérie le rouge david fossard première
explication géologique
là où il ya du pétrole il ya souvent des
poches de gaz et les mêmes compagnies
produisent généralement les deux
énergies deuxième explication financière
lors du choc pétrolier des années 70 les
compagnies craignent de vendre moins de
pétrole au profit du gaz pour être sûr
de ne pas perdre d'argent elle insère
donc dans les contrats de vente un lien
totalement artificielle le gaz est vendu
à gaz de france par exemple à travers
des contrats de long terme et dans ses
contrats de long terme jean les contrats
de 20 ans 25 ans il ya une course de
prix qui fait que le prix que va payer
gaz de france va être indexé sur un
panier de produits pétroliers
résultat chez gdf l'évolution du gaz
suit celle du pétrole sauf qu'en l'état
décide de bloquer le prix ce qu il fait
de moins en moins en janvier gdf a pu
relever ses tarifs de 4 % en avril de 5
et demi près de 10 points en cinq mois
face à ces hausses les associations de
consommateurs s'interrogent sur la
transparence des prix au passage dans
l'augmentation vous fait pas un peu de
gras et ça personne ne peut le dire
puisqu'il ya une autre assise d'une
opacité totale sur la manière dont se
forment le prix du gaz réglementés en
france est une formule de calcul qui est
tenue secrète et qui n'est connu que par
gaz de france et par l'état loin des
factures et des compteurs français
ces accords internationaux font la
richesse des gros pays producteurs de
gaz la russie et l'algérie en pro tour
social avec cette nouvelle journée
d'action aujourd'hui sur différents
sites français du groupe volailler doux
et cela l'appel de plusieurs syndicats
les salariés réclament toujours une
hausse de salaire supérieure aux 0 5 %
proposée par la direction du groupe au
titre de l'année 2008
il y a une semaine nous vous proposions
le témoignage de cette française qui
durant 28 ans avait été violée
séquestrée par son père un témoignage
bouleversant voici ce soir l'heure des
questions comment cette histoire at elle
pu échapper aux proches justice à
l'éducation nationale ou encore aux
services sociaux
voici la suite de cette affaire c'est le
grand format de ce soir fonctionne au
zoo et catherine juste son témoignage a
bouleversé l'opinion
lydia gouardo 45 ans torturée violée
séquestrée pendant 28 ans dans le
grenier de cette bâtisse
le tortionnaire sap et raymond gouardo
son père légal mais pas biologique de
ces viols sont nés six enfants
comment dans un village de 400 habitants
où tout le monde connaît tout le monde
est il possible que personne n'ait rien
vu que personne n'ait rien dit pour
comprendre
nous sommes revenus à coulommes ici la
plupart des habitants avoue que des
rumeurs persistantes parcours et le
village
pourquoi personne ne réagissait pas mon
avis c'est chacun chez soi c'est tout
pour moi c'est chacun chez soi ça
s'arrête là je pense même quand il ya
une dame qui visiblement souffrant le
martyre à l'intérieur de sa maison
mais finissent manger vite par le côté 1
mais des rumeurs c'est pareil c'est
toujours des rumeurs elle et les
vérifier c'est triste pour elle c'est
tout marcel rossignol lui a été
conseiller municipal pendant près de 30
ans il affirme avoir alerté les
autorités
des problèmes de la famille gouardo dans
le village ça se savait qu'il faisait
des enfants avec sa fille oui près
nulles et prévenu les gens de bien sûr
tu prévenu le prévenu lui même le préfet
tout ce qui s'ensuit
ça jamais bouquet rien c'est pour cela
qu'on vous dit il était protégé mais par
qui on ne s'est pas interrogé par leur
hiérarchie les anciens gendarmes en
poste affirme qu'il ne connaissait la
famille gouardo que pour des problèmes
de voisinage
les autorités ont bien retrouvé la trace
d'un procès verbal datant de 1989 mais
le document a été détruit la preuve nous
dit on que ce n'était pas une
dénonciation de crime
dans cette affaire la justice semble
également avoir multiplié les rater
lydia affirme que sa belle-mère la
ébouillanté dans la baignoire en 1971
brûlée au troisième degré plusieurs mois
d'hôpital raymond gouardo attaque en
justice affirmant que l'eau qui arrivait
au robinet était trop chaude procès en
1975 voici la conclusion des médecins
légistes les conditions dans lesquelles
l'accident apparaît être survenue
implique que l'enfant était été
directement plongé à l'intérieur du
lifting
pourquoi la justice n'a t-elle alors pas
demander des comptes à la famille cinq
ans plus tard
lydia gouardo est placée durant trois
mois dans un foyer un juge pour enfants
constate alors de nombreuses fugues dû à
une mésentente avec son père puis
poursuit
bien qu'il ne soit permis de douter de
la réalité et du caractère durable de
ces retrouvailles
il ya lieu néanmoins de donner une suite
favorable à la demande de monsieur
gouardo
lydia est donc rendue à son père selon
ce journaliste qui a révélé l affaire la
justice n'a pas pris la mesure de ce qui
se passait
quand on sait que à peine un an et demi
après lydia était enceinte de son père
les juges n'ont pas eu conscience que
lydia quand même à 18 ans ça faisait
déjà pratiquement dix ans qu'elle se
faisait violer par son père raymond
gouardo abusé de sa fille jusqu'à sa
mort en 1999
l'ex belle mère a quant à elle été
condamné à quatre ans de prison avec
sursis et 6000 euros de dommages et
intérêts jugement trop clément selon
lydia gouardo mais une grande partie des
faits étaient prescrits
son avocat a formulé un recours qui a
peu de chances d'aboutir tout comme un
peu de chances d'aboutir un éventuel
procès contre l'état pour les mêmes
raisons seule satisfaction pour elle
désormais l'espoir que l'histoire
qu'elle raconte permettra à d'autres de
briser le silence
nicolas sarkozy a reçu aujourd'hui à
l'elysée plusieurs ong pour faire le
point sur l'aide à apporter en birmanie
l'actrice jane birkin engagé depuis
longtemps pour la cause berman faisait
partie de la délégation
une mobilisation est essentielle car le
temps là bas est compté pour les
survivants du cyclone mais le principal
obstacle à l'aide mondiale c'est la
junte militaire en place qui ne change
pas ou peu de positions
elle refuse toujours la présence
d'humanitaires étrangers sur son sol
tout cela alors que l'on évoque
maintenant près de cent mille victimes
et plus d'un million de sinistrés
arnaud goûter
sans maison sans eau potable sans
nourriture la mort guette les plus
faibles pour cette vieille dame seul au
bord d'un chemin
l'urgence est une question d'heures et
pourtant malgré la tragédie
voici ce que diffuse aujourd'hui la
télévision d'état des clips qui incite à
voter lors du référendum de demain la
chanson promet un futur merveilleux si
la constitution est approuvée
le pays compte quelque cent mille morts
mais à les entendre
l'urgence est ailleurs il faut voter die
stille alors dépêchez vous dépêchez vous
sur place un journaliste confirme la
priorité du pouvoir c'est le référendum
au détriment des sinistrés certaines
localités
les autorités ont expulsé des fabriques
et s'étaient réfugiées dans des écoles
apparemment ces écoles servirait de
bureaux de vote demain devant les
caméras les généraux distribuer des
vivres est temps de montrer qu'il
maîtrise la situation
la frontière reste fermé aux
humanitaires
onze avions cargos ont pu atterrir c'est
trop peu face au million et demi de
sinistrés alors de bangkok
les ong en vienne a supplié les
autorités ministre s'il vous plaît cette
nourriture doit aller vers ceux qui en
ont besoin
s'il vous plaît laissez nous entrer
l'onu va demander 108 millions de
dollars de fonds d'urgence ce soir la
birmanie a finalement dit oui à une aide
américaine
mais la météo pourrait compliquer les
secours car on annonce maintenant une
semaine d'averses tropicale on a revu
aujourd'hui des fusées nucléaire sur la
place rouge à moscou cela faisait 18 ans
et la chute de l'union soviétique une
telle démonstration de force n'avait pas
eu lieu un défilé des forces
stratégiques pour célébrer la victoire
sur l'allemagne nazie
suivi par le président medvedev et son
tout nouveau premier ministre il
s'appelle vladimir poutine sur place
laurent boussier xavier visé
des milliers d'hommes des dizaines de
blindés et de systèmes d'armes la place
rouge a donc été ce matin le théâtre du
plus grand défilé militaire de la russie
post-soviétique troupes d'élite chars
t-90 missile de dernière génération
une démonstration de la religion une
démonstration apprécié par les beaux
souvenirs
ça fait vraiment plaisir d'être ici je
suis très fier parce que c'est mon pays
et mon armée c'est bien c'est le retour
du patriotisme pour le laisserai
patriotique redonner la fierté au peuple
montré que la russie est de retour sur
le plan stratégique
c'est tel est le message voulu par
vladimir poutine et le président
marseillais particulièrement observé le
tout nouveau missiles stratégiques topol
m
vingt-deux mètres de long pour 11 mines
km de portée maximum grâce à sa mobilité
il est la réponse russe au bouclier
antimissile américain
si pour les rues cette démonstration de
force et une réussite pour les
observateurs étrangers elle ressemble
plutôt à un trompe-l'oeil certes le
budget militaire de la russie a plus que
doublé ces dernières années mais ils ne
représentent pourtant encore aujourd'hui
qu'à peine un dixième du budget
militaire américain
la grande-bretagne maintenant avec cette
enquête on peut le dire étonnante qui
révèle que les anglais seraient les plus
grands gaspilleurs de l'union européenne
cela correspond à quoi eh bien ils ont
ainsi jeté en un an plus de 22 millions
de tonnes de détritus soit 10 millions
de plus que les français en tête de ces
déchets la nourriture on retrouve à
londres
maryse burgot le rang des bois ce
britannique engagée dans la chasse aux
gaspillages n'achète jamais sa
nourriture ils la trouvent dans les
poubelles celles des supermarchés ou des
particuliers
la date de péremption de ses pommes de
terre n'est pas dépassé même chose pour
ses oranges au moins cette nourriture ne
se retrouvera pas dans les décharges
sont que des bonnes choses qui viennent
d'egypte de france ou d'ailleurs
incroyable statistique les ménages
britanniques jette un tiers de la
nourriture qu'ils achètent chaque jour
plus d'un
en deuil à ourthe 90 ha mais vont à la
poubelle un million et demi de bananes
et presque autant de saucisses c'est
comme si les sujets de sa majesté
mettait directement dans les ordures
chaque année près de sept cent soixante
dix euros le problème c'est qu'on s'en
rend même plus compte que l'on jette
c'est devenu une habitude de traiter
comme ça notre nourriture les
britanniques comme les français dans une
moindre mesure ont donc oublier les
rationnements de la guerre
ceux qui ont connu ces temps difficiles
se permettent d'ailleurs quelques
conseils et vous et faites une liste de
ceux dont vous avez besoin
et quand vous êtes au supermarché
chercher ces choses mais ne regarder ni
à droite ni à gauche
cette culture du gaspillage permettra en
tout cas ce soir à notre fouilleurs de
poubelles de dîners tout à fait
correctement et gratuitement le sport
football et ce week-end sera celui du
suspense pour de nombreux clubs que ce
soit en haut ou en bas du classement
bordeaux s'est rapproché de lyon et pour
le maintien à deux journées de la fin
trois équipes sont toujours à la lutte
demain nous irons à lens
écouter les supporters inquiet à
quelques heures du match face à lille ce
soir coup de projecteur sur le paris
saint-germain julien benetteau si l'un
d'eux bas malgré les apparences les
joueurs du psg ne roule pas des
mécaniques
l'heure est grave pour le deuxième
budget de ligue 1 menacé de relégation
dernier entraînement à huis clos cet
après midi au parc des princes demain
contre saint-etienne paris jouera quoi
qu'on en dise avec la peur de descendre
en ligue 2 baudon par la peur au ventre
pour un match de football mais bon
l'espoir quand même deux
deux pas on voit les équipes de digby on
n'a pas envie de se taper ça pendant un
an quoi c'est la finale du championnat
recolle c'est maintenant ou jamais c'est
sûr que si on gagne pas c'est très très
loin
le psg n'a jamais existé dans ce
championnat c'est le classement qui le
dit neuvième au mieux 18e ce soir une
place synonyme de relégation avec ce
parcours catastrophique le club n'a
cessé de s'attirer les foudres de ses
sulfureux supporters qui sont même allés
jusqu'à menacer physiquement leur idole
et même si le paris saint germain s'est
qualifié pour la finale de la coupe de
france
la perspective d'un nouveau titre ne
fait rêver personne dans l'entourage du
club
la ligue 2 est dans toutes les têtes les
dirigeants réclament l'union sacrée on
est en danger mais il n'empêche on est
très motivé lucide et très confiants les
efforts que nous avons à faire demain
soir paris comptera une dernière fois
sur son buteur providentiel le portugais
pauleta fera ses adieux au parc des
princes il aura marqué l'histoire du
club avec ses 109 buts en quatre ans
symbole d'un psg au destin incertain
entre grandeur et décadence
affaire à suivre demain étonnants
voyageurs c'est le nom du festival du
livre et du film qui se tient ce
week-end à saint-malo un festival qui
accueillera cette année l'acteur et
romancier bernard giraudeau un grand
voyageur et qui publie en collaboration
avec un dessinateur ses carnets de
voyage sur sa jeunesse de mac l'eau
marylène bono et vincent barral c'est
l'histoire d'une rencontre celle d'un
auteur de bandes dessinées gestion
caillou et de l'acteur écrivain bernard
giraudeau leur passion commune la mer et
les voyages
en 2006 ils ont embarqué ensemble sur la
jeanne d'arc
bernard giraudeau il y avait passé deux
ans comme apprenti mécanicien dans les
années 60 et il a fait deux fois le tour
du monde
il avait raconté dans son livre à marin
à l'ancré
désormais c'est avec les dessins de
caillots qu'il raconte ses souvenirs a
déjà tant je pensais les pico les voir
les filles mais visiter aussi c'est vrai
j'ai sûrement moins but et moins
- était au bordel que les autres surnoms
c'était ma jeunesse c'était la mariée et
je me suis aperçu que c'était une
jeunesse extrêmement violente quand je
suis revenu à paris vingt ans que j'ai
présentées conservatoire à 23 ans et que
les copains qui avaient mon âge santé du
lycée quoi les carnets de voyage de
bernard giraudeau ont fait rêver le
dessinateur pris par son écriture j'ai
choisi verna mois s'est choisie je suis
allé vers lui
parce qu'il me semblait quelques années
d'écart avec des différences c'est le
propos du ligne pour moi cette histoire
là ces histoires de de la jeunesse qui
découvre le monde
qu'est-ce décourage même des images et
des mots qui nous apprennent comment se
dérouler la vie quotidienne à bord du
bâtiment militaire commandant mécano
bateau mécano il ya un amour la machine
la machine à vapeur
j'ai des brûlures de tout ça il ya un
amour de du du métier qu'on retrouve
quand même assez rarement ailleurs
ensuivie r97 et l'immatriculation de la
jeanne d'arc
cet album est un tour du monde
originales racontées par deux étonnants
voyageurs
voilà avant de terminer journal je
rappelle l'une des informations de ce
vendredi la mort de pascal sevran à
l'âge de 62 ans il s'est éteint à
victime d'un cancer
ses amis sont publics sont touchés et
triste bien sûr ce soir il a été durant
toute sa vie l'un des plus ardents
défenseurs de la chanson française
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui mais également
un homme de lettres
voilà pour l'actualité de ce vendredi
merci des fidèles à l'information sur
france 2 demain je vous retrouve dès 13h
avec le journal et le magazine dans un
instant la météo tania young
20h50 les deux derniers épisodes de
votre saga le silence de l'épervier avec
line renaud
22h35 hommage à pascal sevran
france 2 diffusera un numéro spécial de
vivement dimanche passé une très belle
soirée on se quitte en chansons avec
pascal se vend à demain
avoir 18 ans il était beau comme un
enfant fort que nous
c'était l'été évidemment
tu a compté ans
en gagner d'autres
tarn
à tech 1
sur tes yeux
ça va faire
quand il s'est approché de toi tu aurais
fait
de toi
pour lui
et les
à voir
suite